hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
paranormal oh hello
don't sleep Oh jerk don't tell me what
to do I'll do whatever I wanna although
that last scream was a bit wonky that
baby that lady had that baby okay
everything is still flowing blood which
is good you know what is that who's that
that's the garage wait a minute that
telling me something
two four five garage hang on a tick also
the safe thing nice Oh whoo two four
five
yeah oh yeah this must be the key to the
basement
I don't want that Oh with that at all
where's my camera battery there's my
camera battery indicator level why do
you keep body-slamming my my that's um
that'll be awfully economic when we sit
to watch TV I suppose let's go to the
basement the pipes the pipes up
[Music]
is this a basement door alot squeaker
than it should have been oh hello you
Sarah
Jennifer Marcus Jeremy Sarah alright
let's go I suppose Hey stop jerking
around please
oh no how am I gonna get out wait no
what
don't want to never sure here's what the
clicker you press key damn baby
I've also got the volume like way
cranked up in my headphones and I the
volume thing is broken so huh huh huh
don't kill me oh no I'm so freaking out
[Music]
December 21st 1984 I've been returning
to that room in the basement every day
since the deaths it makes me feel better
more at peace December 23rd 1984 a woman
from the hidden room has been following
me ever since I saw her the presence
I've been feeling isn't Marcus it never
was she kills everyone I love why what
have I done god I don't know December
25th 1984 Christmas is just another
reminder that Jesus doesn't give a damn
about protecting me hmm Satan's [ __ ]
killed everyone I loved and now she
stalks me follows me on Smee fun times
buddy January 11th 1985 I have the urge
to kill both nice my mind being tainted
yeah the very soul being perverted and
contorted by this evil place I would
have said it in other ways by offset
foot in that room I don't know is this
why Marcus acted so strangely before he
died yes
it's the same thing happening to me
pretty much January 15th for 1885 if
anybody reads this I apologize for
anything I've done
uh-huh destroy the house gas leak
utility closet basement stop this evil
okey dokey so I guess that's my
objective not dead
oh god I gotta get here gotta get a
freaking frack out of this friggin
basement
let me out my camera is probably gonna
run that battery soon oh shut up baby is
open huh guess whoa I see you I mean I
don't see you cuz its pitch black
Oh
[Music]
woman hello nanny hours we successfully
stopped the fire of the house one set of
human remains was found basement of the
home the nature of the fire appears to
be gas related and purely accidental
though the matter will be investigated
thoroughly by our department the
deceased has been identified as Mattel
Clark douche McGee
[Music]
dun-dun-duh more always a tragedy when
something like that happens on a
brighter note the weather on the coast
is set to keep the sun shining which
means this weekend will be the perfect
weekend to go to the beach wait what is
my game just bugging out
by being all white am I supposed to be
seeing something else here am I supposed
to be seeing credits here really is that
is that what's supposed to happen
I guess this game is kind of buggy hang
on man
one second one second guys ah damn it
damn it all right I'm not I'm not sure
what just happened there please um if
you guys have played this before let me
know what the heck just happened cuz I
am utterly confused well I'm not utterly
I know that I was trying to destroy the
house or something and maybe that pipe
upstairs house was not detached that so
that the rest of the house had burned
down or something like that or but going
into the basement I had no idea that I
was put to burn it down the first place
so let me know I mean I don't think I'm
done with this game I don't think I saw
everything there was to see that might
have been one of possible multiple
endings and also I couldn't even see
what was going on down there because
practically was just pitch blackness I'm
not sure this game is still in beta
technically it was released later this
month oh hi
saw that so um let me know guys write in
the comments below but I guess I'll end
of here I don't want to start up a whole
new ones to have to end it as soon as
the intro sequence go out so I will end
it here which is a damn shame I mean I
was I was really like I was really
interested in that it's like huh I'm not
even exactly sure what I should do about
that I mean I guess who would start
bugging and early because the camera the
battery indicator just went away early
on and I don't know but I mean of that I
was it was like crazy scary hello but
it's not that you loose camper I was
like I don't know that friggin baby in
the bathroom startled me more than
anything it's just a big baby's head
right in the mirror freaky furgus hell
but anyway so I'm just dragging on so uh
I hate to end an episode early but let
me know in the comments below what I'm
supposed to do next if I need to start a
new game to start over or if there's a
procedure that I need to take or if I've
explored everything this might be the
end so please let me know thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always we'll see you in the
next part video thing bye bye